يبدو ان المشاهد المرعبه باتت مالوفه في
محافظه هاتاي واحده من اكثر الاماكن تضررا
من زلزال الساده من فبراير بعدها باسبوعين
العشرين من فبراير كانت فرق الانقاذ
المحليه والدوليه على وشك انهاء مهمتها في
الولايه عندما اعلنت اداره الكوارث
التركيه اعاده التوجيه الفرق للمدينه مره
اخرى السبب هو زلزال جديد بقوه 6.4 درجات
على مقياس ريخطر بالصدفه وفي هاتاي في نفس
الوقت كان وزيره الدفاع والصحه ورئيس
الاركان التركيه يعقدون اجتماعا في مركز
اداره الكوارث حدث الزلزال خرجوا من
المبنى وانتظروا في احدى الحدائق وبين
هذين الزلزالين كانت هناك اكثر من 9000
ارتداديه اخرها اليوم يعني ان الزلزال
الاول يتبع لقانون اموري ومعناه ان معدل
الهزات الارتداديه قد تستمر لشهور سنوات
رغم انها تتناقص مع مرور الزمن لكن ورغم
ان الزلزال الاخير كان اقل بخمسه وعشرين
ضعفا من الزلزال الاول لكنه كان قويا هناك
ضحايا 42 مصابا في شمال غربيه سوريا
وانهار عدد من المباني ورغم انه قوي شعر
به سكان مصر وفلسطين ولبنان لكن حصيلته
كانت ضئيله عوامل عده حدت من اثاره
[موسيقى]
الاتراك باتوا يعانون من رهاب الزلازل هل
يمكن ان تحدث موجه اكبر في مدن منكوبه
ومدن اخرى
الزلزال الاول جاء نتيجه الانتقال بين
الصدع البحر الميت وصدع شرق الاناضول الذي
يبدا بمدينه هاتاي بمدينه موش امر ادى الى
تمزيق جزء كبير من ثلث الجنوبي الغربي من
صدع شرق الاناضول وكذلك الجزء الشمالي من
الصدع البحر الميت الخوف هنا ان يزيد
الضغط على غرب او يسار منطقه الزلزال
ايمكن ان تحدث زلازل اخرى او حتى تسونامي
في قبرص اضنه وبالقرب من بحر ايجاد هناك
خطر اخر موجود منذ 2018 فرصه بنسبه
95% ان يضرب الزلزال اسطنبول زلزال بقوه
سبع درجات او اقوى والسبب توسع الزلزاليه
مع التشققات التي احدثها زلزاله 1912 و
1999 بمنطقه صدع شمال الاناضول وهي واحده
من اكثر مناطق الصدع نشاطا وربما فتكا في
العالم هذه التشققات زادت بالقرب من بحر
مرمره الذي سيكون مصدر الزلزال اسطنبول ان
حدث وفي بحر اخر الابيض المتوسط التخوف من
تسونامي قريب خاصه مع الزلازل الزلزال
الجديد الذي ضرب هاتاي الساحليه وانتشار
صور تظهر تراجع منسوب مياه البحر علميا
يبدو السيناريو مستبعدا العلماء اكدوا ان
تراجع المياه يعود لعامل المد والجزر
المتوقع ان يحدث مره ثانيه في الشهر
والنقطه الثانيه يجب ان يكون الزلزال قويا
سبع بسبع درجات على الاقل واكثر من ثماني
درجات للحصول على تسونامي خطر الزلزال
الاول كان قريبا من ثماني درجات لكن ما
جعلت تسونامي امرا غير وارد هو بعده عن
البحر الاخير وان كان اقرب للبحر كونها
تاي مدينه ساحليه كانت قوته قلت عن سبع
درجات
وليقعد تسونامي ايضا يجب ان يتسبب الزلزال
في حركه راسيه لقاع البحر تصل الى عده
امطار بينما تكون حركه صدى فالق شرق
الاناضول غالبا افقيه وليست راسيه